- [Narrator] Ugh, brain freeze.
It's awful, that sharp,
searing pain in your forehead.
But you know what's even worse?
Not everyone gets it.
That's right, some people can suck down
as many milkshakes as they
want and never feel a thing.
Life is so unfair.
And you know what else?
These lucky people are
ruining it for scientists too.
Brain freeze is one of
those scientific mysteries
that's been around since the 1800s.
Just throw it in there
with UFOs and crop circles.
We may never know the
real reason behind them.
Ah, maybe that's a bit of an exaggeration
but here's the thing,
the leading theories for
what causes a brain freeze
have to do with a physical response
that everyone should feel.
The way scientists think it works is this:
Brain freeze happens when something cold
hits the roof of your mouth
where it triggers your trigeminal nerve.
It's the nerve in charge
of the sensations you feel
around the front of your head.
That's why when you freeze
it to sub-zero temperatures,
the pain is around the
temple and the forehead.
In fact, different nerves
cause pain in different
parts of your head.
A toothache, for example, can
irritate the mandibular nerve
causing pain near the central skull.
But, when it comes to brain
freeze, the source of the pain
is different from most other headaches.
Turns out it's similar to
why your feet and hands sting
when they get too cold.
Your body floods that area with blood
to try and return it to body temperature
and in the process your
blood vessels expand,
which causes that throbbing pain.
Similarly, during a brain freeze,
blood vessels in your brain widen
sending a rush of blood
to the roof of your mouth
and, in the process, causing pain.
Now, the trigeminal nerve is
a natural part of the body,
so if it's the real cause of brain freeze
then that means everyone should get it.
So why do scientists estimate
that only 37% of Americans,
actually, feel it.
And, for that matter,
41% of children in Taiwan
and 15% of the adults in Denmark,
according to another study.
Researchers can only speculate.
Maybe the trigeminal
nerve is less sensitive
in certain demographics.
One thing that does seem to be clear
is that people who do
experience brain freeze
may also be more susceptible
to another kind of mysterious
headache, migraines.
In one small study, 93%
of migraine patients
were also prone to brain freeze,
which has led researchers to suspect
that the trigeminal nerve
also plays a key role in migraines.
Whatever the reason, just hang in there.
Brain freezes, usually,
only last 20 or 30 seconds.
You could take those seconds
to remember not to slurp
so quickly next time.
What else do you want to
know about the human body?
Let us know in the comments
and thanks for watching.